Attorney General Jeff Sessions our buddy
might have committed perjury again
remember that Jeff Sessions just fired
deputy FBI director Andrew McCabe for in
part this is so funny lack of candor
during testimony we already know that
back in March of 2017 in a hearing Jeff
sessions said he had no communication
with Russians during the Trump campaign
we later learned that he actually had
multiple communications with Russians
this was the first live from this sort
of series of Lies of course there are
lots of other Jeff Sessions lies
unrelated to this series but just as a
reminder this is how that went down when
being questioned by Al Franken and if
there is any evidence that anyone
affiliated with the Trump campaign
communicated with the Russian government
in the course of this campaign what will
you do senator Franken I'm not aware of
any of those activities I have been
called a surrogate at a time or two in
that campaign and I did not have
communications with the Russians and I'm
unable to comment on total lie probably
perjury he'll never get in trouble for
it though fill the swamp and move on
okay we thought we were done and and
beyond it but sessions testified again a
couple of times including in November of
2017 and that time it was before the
House Judiciary Committee and it appears
that sessions also lied during that
hearing he was asked about now indicted
Trump advisor George papadopolis
Papadopoulos had proposed that Donald
Trump's campaign reach out to Russia
during that meeting that took place on
March 31st of 2016
Trump was at that meeting sessions was
at that meeting other top Trump staff
were at that meeting sessions claimed
during the testimony that he pushed back
against them
that he thought reaching out to Russia
was a bad idea and that he wanted to
make sure everybody in the room knew
that he thought it was a bad idea
unfortunately it appears that that was
also a lie because Reuters is now
reporting that three people who were at
the meeting said no it's not true
sessions expressed no objection
whatsoever to reaching out to Russia and
these three individuals say they've also
spoken to Robert molars investigators
and told Robert molars team that it
wasn't true what Jeff sessions said he
posed no objection whatsoever to
reaching out to Russia now there is I
want to be thorough I'm not hiding
anything from you there's a fourth
person who was at the meeting who says
no no Jeff sessions is telling the truth
he did push back so currently it's three
to one on this issue we can think about
who to believe right do we believe the
recused Attorney General who's already
been caught lying or do we believe the
three people who were in the room and
were interviewed by Robert Moeller's
team and said no sessions didn't push
back at George papadopolis suggestion
that we reach out to Russia you judge
for yourself who you want to believe but
the really depressing part of all of
this is that no one's gonna go after
sessions for perjury right there have
been no consequences for sessions lies
back from March of 2017
there have been no consequences for
sessions for recusing himself on
anything related to Russia and then
firing people specifically to interfere
with the Russia investigation as
admitted by Donald Trump they currently
control every aspect of the government
they seem to be unable to control Robert
Moeller which is good right like we hope
that they're not controlling robert
muller and that that investigation will
happen fully and fairly but we're not
gonna see anybody within trump's
administration hold jeff Sessions
accountable here for recusing and then
being involved and then lying once
during testimony to the Senate and once
during testimony at least once during
testimony to the house Trump could
remove sessions for the lies yeah right
and also we could argue that firing
sessions in a way might be a step
towards firing Muller but I think Pat we
just have to come to terms with the
reality that there's not going to be a
repercussion sessions for having done
this it's not gonna happen and
unfortunately I think sessions view of
in the public has been tarnished I agree
for a time even though we had
disagreements with him he could be seen
as a patriot because he did decide to
recuse himself he's not a complete
Lackey for Trump and it looked like he
wasn't willing to make those contacts
with Russia now we don't know what to
believe yet there was a period of about
three and a half minutes that Pat's
referring to where we had plausible
belief
of what Jeff sessions said before it was
instantly fact-check and realized he was
lying I mean let no it was longer than
three and a half minutes but you're
right like bye and it's not that I would
call him a patriot oh yeah but you're
saying as a straight and standard by the
standards of the committed trumpets
which are shifting standards by the way
you could sort of say like this guy is
not the worst guy out there but yeah
that's gone out the window and there
we're gonna have to just realize that
hopefully some people will be held
accountable for this entire thing that
is being investigated but we're gonna
have to come to terms with the reality
that a lot of them just or not they're
not going to be held accountable and
it's sad I don't know what else to tell
you I wish I had something else I could
say a word of inspiration but I don't as
you know Donald Trump has fired the
Secretary of State Rex Tillerson whether
it was because of Russia or to protect
Jared Kushner we don't quite know we
might never know but what we do know is
that Ivanka Trump the president's
daughter whose band by nepotism laws
from having a formal position in the
administration is sitting in for the
Secretary of State at an upcoming
meeting with the South Korean foreign
minister and the White House is
confirming this the White House is
saying yeah Ivanka who as I told you
last week is still set to her in about a
million dollars this year from the Trump
family business from which she has not
separated herself she will be meeting
with Kang kumoi
of South Korea not only does Ivanka
Trump not have a formal position in the
White House because she can't not only
does she have business interests in the
country of South Korea from which she
still is going to earn money she doesn't
even have a permanent security clearance
presumably because of the problems with
Jared Kushner
and multiple false sf-86 vetting form
submissions and she is going to be doing
something that would typically be the
purview of the Secretary of State's in
related news a panel of Bachelor
contestants as well as the Long Island
medium that psychic woman are gonna be
filling in from Mike Pompeo a CIA
director while he goes through the
process of becoming separate separate
Secretary of State how low are we going
to go here am I being too tough on
Ivanka like can we say that because she
designs some really nice handbag
oh wait a second no they actually paid
someone else to design the handbags I
might prefer the actual Ivanka handbag
designer / Ivanka meet with the South
Korean Foreign Minister all joking aside
this is probably illegal okay there's a
piece of law so we've got the
anti-nepotism laws which say why Ivanka
can't have an official position in the
government there's something else called
inherently governmental functions which
is five US Code 31:10 subsection
employment of relatives which
specifically says there are certain
government functions that are so
intimately related to the public
interest that they can only be performed
by a government employee
this has to be adjudicated right this is
subjective but how can anyone argue that
the functions of the Secretary of State
are not inherently governmental
functions Ivanka Trump is a private
citizen and thus should be forbidden
from participating in these functions
and yet she is and it appears to violate
that law it appears as though there may
be other violations emoluments questions
so much of what's going on here and part
of this of course has to do with the
broader problem of just unfilled
positions in the Trump administration
two-thirds of the top nine jobs meaning
six of the top nine jobs at the State
Department are currently empty this is
not normal and I keep going back to this
point the real tragedy of the Trump
debacle is that it has made ignorant
popular again okay it's put a ton of
energy behind those who defend lack of
knowledge and lack of intellectual
curiosity and it goes way beyond the
micro of Ivanka sitting there as
Secretary of State or Trump paying a
porn star off or Trump being the puppet
of a foreign government we can undo a
lot of the damage that Trump does some
of it we won't be able to undo but it's
going to take a long time to recover
from the broader idea that speaking like
Trump doing diplomacy or not doing it
the way the Trump administration is
doing it the pseudo intellectualism and
anti intellectualism that I've been
talking about
for a while now that has lasting damage
just look at education around the world
look at math and science scores from
other countries compared to the United
States that is going to be in my mind
the most long term destructive impact of
the trump administration and I I don't
exactly know how we're going to recover
from it I'm out of time no voicemail
today it was gonna be a good one it
really was but I'll get to it tomorrow
fantastic bonus show coming up for you
today as well if you ever watch Fox News
and who could blame you if you don't you
might be familiar with the face or name
of retired lieutenant colonel ralph
peters a longtime Fox News contributor
on the network
he has quit in shame self-described
shame saying he's ashamed of the
network's coverage and he emailed his
colleagues and that email has been
obtained by BuzzFeed and if his name
rings a bell and you don't watch Fox
News it might be because this is the
same guy who was suspended by Fox News
in 2015 for calling President Obama a
quote total [ __ ] we covered it at the
time during an appearance on the Fox
Business Network
I've excerpted just the relevant parts
of Ralph Peters email to his colleagues
explaining why he's going to be quitting
Fox News where he said quote I feel
compelled to explain why I have to leave
I swore to support and defend the
Constitution and that oath did not
expire when I took off my uniform today
I feel that Fox News is assaulting our
constitutional order and the rule of law
while fostering corrosive and
unjustified paranoia among viewers over
my decade with Fox I long was proud of
the Association now I am ashamed
Fox is degenerated from providing a
legitimate and much-needed outlet for
conservative voices to a mere propaganda
machine for a destructive and ethically
ruinous administration when primetime
hosts who have never served our country
in any capacity dismiss facts and
empirical reality to launch profoundly
dishonest attacks on the FBI the Justice
Department's the court the courts the
intelligence community in which I served
and not least a model public servant and
genuine war hero such as Robert Muller
all the while
our mongering with lurid warnings of
deep state matcha nations machinations I
cannot be part of the same organization
Fox News is now wittingly harming our
system of government for profit going on
to say as a Russia analyst for many
years it also has appalled me that hosts
who made their reputations as super
patriots and who justifiably savaged
President Obama first duplicitous faulty
with Putin now advanced Putin's agenda
by making light of Russian penetration
of our elections and the Trump campaign
and by the way as an intelligence
professional I can tell you that the
steel dossier rings true that's how the
Russians do things the result is that we
have an American president who is
terrified of his counterpart in Moscow
Fox News has crossed the line
for the guy who called Obama a total
[ __ ] right this is a real hardcore
ideologically committed right winger and
he is calling out Fox's propaganda and
calling out Trump as being Putin's
puppet and all of a sudden he goes in
the eyes of the Fox News audience from
conservative hero to unpatriotic stooge
as far as they're concerned and I want
to be super clear here Ralph Peters is
no hero he is not even an admirable
person he has a long long track record
of the most horrifying and disgusting
views and statements he is truly a
raging clown but even he sees what it is
that's going on at Fox and he talks
about his decade with Fox News during
that decade Fox News was going after
Obama for his choice of mustard right
and Peters apparently felt okay staying
then so I'm not making this guy appear
to be a good guy in any way pat but what
I am Telling You is that someone as
heinous in their views as this guy even
sees what's going on judging by that
statement he wants a virtue bestowed on
him for making this decision annually
treated like a hero but yet he was
complicit for that 10-year period yeah
but on the other hand I think Fox News
has gotten worse I agree from
administration began no it's been and
you know what I don't think it's that
Fox News has necessarily gotten worse
it's just that at this point it's even
harder to pretend like we don't see
what's going on like when Bush was
president and they were all talking
constantly about just how great he is
and how great everything is it was at
least a more coherent narrative in terms
of how the sort of ideologically
committed right winger would buy into it
but now it's getting even hard for the
ideologically committed right-wingers to
just pretend that the Fox narrative is
the accurate one and listen he made the
right decision albeit ten years too late
right and now Fox News is going after
the intelligence community and he said
that he served the intelligence
community yeah so he's saying oh now
it's like you're attacking me it feels
personal now yeah let's not pretend that
this is anything but a guy who has been
totally complacent and complicit in the
garbage from Fox News who just sort of
feels like he's been pushed over the
edge maybe partially because he feels
personally attacked by the narrative
from Fox News about the Intel community
right decision glad to see him go
not a hero should have done it a decade
ago so we already know that adult film
actress stormy Daniels was paid a
hundred and thirty thousand bucks in
hush money she also signed a
nondisclosure agreement for an alleged
affair with Donald Trump that took place
as far as we knew before Trump was
President of the United States right
when Trump was a private citizen and
that's something that his defenders have
been focusing on this is stuff that
Trump allegedly did while he was a
private citizen but now we're hearing
more from stormy Daniels lawyer Michael
avenatti who appeared in a number of CNN
interviews recently one with Jake Tapper
and he's now alleging a lot of different
stuff none all of which individually
would be totally blockbuster the first
allegation being that some of these
incidents between stormy Daniels and
President Donald Trump took place while
Donald Trump was president which now is
painting a drastically different
scenario in situation
here's clip number one obviously a big
debate about how relevant an
extramarital affair when Donald Trump
was a private citizen and alleged
extramarital affair is to the job he's
doing right now is there anything in the
litany of accusations you would call
them facts that surround this case that
happened while Donald Trump was
president yes
can you go any further than that no and
to those who say hey this is just an
alleged affair back when Donald Trump
was a private citizen who cares
you would say it's all about the
cover-up
all right Michael avenatti thank you so
much for your time appreciate the other
picked big piece of news from stormy
Daniels attorney is that she was
physically threatened to not talk about
what she knew that's what Michael
avenatti said to CNN's Chris Cuomo let's
look at that clip
what are you alleging was done to your
client in terms of pressure to stay
quiet well I'm not alleging anything I'm
stating a fact and the fact is that my
client was physically threatened to stay
silent about what she knew about Donald
Trump the details surrounding that she's
going to discuss I'm sure on the 60
Minutes interview on March 25 and the
American people are going to weigh her
veracity and the third piece of alleged
news is that there are six more women
with similar stories about Donald Trump
although avenatti says he's not yet
vetted those stories in total this one's
with Anderson Cooper do you find the
stories of these other women who you say
have come to you are credible or are
there any similarities in terms of
circumstances
good evening Anderson as of tonight
we've been approached by six separate
women with similar stories to my client
I want to stress that we have not vetted
these stories to any great degree
however the the initial consultations
the initial information that we're
receiving indicates that there are some
striking similarities between their
stories and that of my client miss
Clifford can you say if any of these
women have non-disclosure agreements yes
they do at least two of them can you say
can you say is it from the same LLC that
Michael Cohen set up before for the one
with stormy Daniels we don't know yet
Wow there's lots of little facts that
start to make more sense when you hear
this stuff like for example months ago
reported to you the white house is no
longer releasing visitor logs all right
we figured probably has to do with
lobbyists hiding the fact that the
swamps not really being drained maybe it
did
maybe it had to do with this that there
were people visiting Trump at the White
House that they didn't want to be
publicly known it's almost impossible at
this point to keep track of all the
little details but what I think is clear
is that listen stormy Daniels played a
very small role in this administration
yes she was at the White House yes she
was involved in debriefing the president
but it's not the same type of debriefing
that Steven Bannon was doing when we
said he would debrief the president
I get the sense that attorney Michael
avenatti
is doing a really good job here of
letting Trump and his attorney Michael
Cohen dig their own graves but who does
this avenatti guy think he is he
probably went to some loser fake news
school where they teach all sorts of oh
wait a vinod he went to University of
Pennsylvania same astronomy well listen
he didn't go to Wharton that's the one
department at UPenn where the actual
smart people go this really puts the
rush of stuff in context for me right
Trump bestow on us to believe that
there's just no way Trump could be
manipulated by a foreign power that
specializes in this stuff yet a porn
star has him over a barrel and it's
unrealistic that Putin would we are
going to be following this not because I
really care that much about what stormy
Daniels did or didn't do it's that we
care about as Michael avenatti said the
legality of the cover-up sort of lost
between the news of Rex Tillerson firing
and the firing of deputy FBI director
Andrew McCabe was the request and not
really a request the subpoena from
special prosecutor Robert Muller of the
Trump Organization and of course the
Trump Organization is not the Trump
campaign the Trump Organization is
Trump's business entity and specifically
Robert Muller subpoenaed documents a
number of documents including some
related to Russia now this is relevant
for two different reasons before I get
to the one about the investigation let's
talk about the Moller part of this you
might remember that back in July of 2017
Donald Trump was asked by New York Times
reporters whether if Robert Muller
starts to look at his personal finances
his family's finances unrelated to
Russia whether that would signify sort
of the crossing of a red line and Trump
said that it would so let's review that
transcript from the New York Times where
Trump was asked last thing if Muller was
looking at your finances and your family
finances unrelated to Russia is that a
red line and Maggie Haberman added would
that be a breach of what his actual
charges and Trump said I would say yeah
I would say yes by the way I would say I
don't I don't I mean it's possible
there's a condo or something so you know
I sell a lot of condo units and somebody
from Russia buys a condo who knows and
then he goes on and on with his
unintelligible rents but the point here
is that Trump made very clear that if
Robert Muller went beyond whatever Trump
thought his scope should be at the time
into Trump's family finances which of
course mostly are tied up in the Trump
Organization that that would be a red
line
Robert Muller has now subpoenaed
documents from the Trump Organization
some of which are related to Russia
according to two people briefed about
this some of which presumably might be
related more generally to the business
and financial activities of trumps
business this is notable in part because
number one it's the first time that we
know of during the Russia investigation
where Muller is demanding Trump business
records and that gets us another half
step or full step closer to Donald Trump
personally which seems to be happening
every week but the more notable part of
it and I haven't seen this discussed as
much is that there is a subpoena right
all along
what Trump's lawyers have said is we
believe there's nothing here and we want
this to end
but we're cooperating with Muller and we
are responding to all of the requests
that we get from Robert Muller
responding to requests doesn't
necessarily mean that they're giving
Muller the documents that he asks for
and that's what raises the question
about the need for a subpoena if you've
given a subpoena to the Trump lawyers
for these documents to me it means one
of two things one molar already asked
for the documents and didn't get them so
now he's subpoenaing the documents Oh
he has for some reason knowledge that
requesting the documents alone isn't
going to get them because the act of
sending a subpoena is newsworthy in and
of itself right so number one redline
possibly crossed
we've got mccabe fired Comey fired isn't
firing Mulder the next step or at least
trying to that's number one and number
two why is it that a subpoena was even
necessary here and I I was just thinking
how funny it was thinking back to that
July 2017 interview when Trump says it
would be a red line to look into my
personal finances isn't that basically
saying look at my personal find finances
it's like if someone says officer I
definitely don't know anything about
illegal drugs but if I did know
something about it I absolutely would
not have the legal drugs the illegal
drugs in my glove compartment so
definitely no need to look there at all
it's calling attention to where it is
that Robert Mulder should be focusing
his energy and if there is one good
piece of information related to the
possible firing of Muller it's that even
though we learned a few days ago that
this subpoena was submitted was served
to Trump it actually is from weeks ago
so I'm sort of hoping that the fact that
the subpoena is actually several weeks
old means Donald Trump is not going to
fire
Robert Muller since presumably he would
have already done that when he learned
of the subpoena again unless Trump's
lawyers are keeping news of the subpoena
from Trump which I can't imagine they
are I don't want to dwell on this aspect
of the story too much because there's
just been so much Trump Russia stuff in
the last 72 hours but we're in a
situation where a subpoena of Trump
business documents is only ranking like
fourth or fifth in the major breaking
stories of the last 72 to 96 hours with
the the big picture is we are rapidly
heading towards a major confrontation on
this issue and quite frankly I
personally can't wait for that to happen
you might have learned the other day
that Russia had a quote election in
which Vladimir Putin quote did really
well receiving quo
almost 77% of the vote then we all woke
up from that total fantasy world as
dozens and dozens of videos of people
literally stuffing ballot boxes with
stacks of ballots have been released we
have a ton of videos of this the
Washington Post put one together where
you can see people just putting stacks
of paper into these ballots and of
course the defense has been well that
all these individuals might have
collected a bunch of people's ballots
and put them in at once do you see that
that's how the polling place is set up I
mean where where are these ballots
coming from it makes absolutely no sense
and in order to make the absurd 77% of
the vote number that Putin supposedly
received appears slightly more
mathematically believable the opposition
leader Alexei Navalny says that the
official turnout numbers were also
inflated reported as sixty seven point
five percent Navalny saying that that's
actually like ten percentage points
higher than the real turnout again this
is according to opposition candidate
Navalny 77 cent percent for Vladimir
Putin the highest ever in a Russian
presidential election now you might say
to me hey David listen stuffing ballots
into ballot boxes is a really low-tech
and inefficient way to help Putin if
there was real centralized corruption
here you would do it in some other way
you're not gonna physically send people
out there to stuffed ballot boxes well
that's right but what you're forgetting
is Putin didn't need these votes to win
right I'm not saying Putin would have
lost without the ballot stuffing what
I'm saying is he wouldn't have won by as
much it would have just been much closer
I don't even know that Putin necessarily
needs to be in on this Pat because local
governments want to please Putin the
last thing you want to be is the local
official whose district didn't have a
solid turnout for Putin so I'm not even
alleging necessarily that Vladimir Putin
was directly coordinating this but if
the defenses are just laughable oh
here's one Putin's approval rating is
something like eighty one percent eighty
three percent and that's in line with
the percentage of the vote that he got
well Benjamin fine must have been fine
there's absolutely no problem with
ever one other funny video to show you
here someone places a grew a bunch of
balloons right in front of the camera at
a polling place a woman walks over and
then just casually all of a sudden
exactly where the camera is she just
moves a bunch of balloons right in front
but this is just the best isn't it you
know you would think that at this point
we would we would want to be beyond this
type of stuff but we were not and a
funny defense of the videos is okay fine
listen David you're right it's ballot
stuffing but we don't know which
candidates supporters are stuffing the
ballots you can't say for sure that
those are Putin ballots that are being
stuffed in there
give me a break right in order to
believe that these were opposition
ballots stuffings you have to first
explain how were they able to get away
with that despite Putin's cronies
controlling endless numbers of polling
places and that would also imply it but
imply that Putin didn't just set a
record with 77% of the vote he arguably
had even more of the vote but because of
opposition ballot stuffing the number
was inaccurately low I mean who would
believe that stuff you've got yeah I
spend disbelief in total to believe
people are still questioning whether or
not Russia influence the US presidential
election they're doing it for their own
elections of course they are there is a
tweet that was put out by Edward Snowden
about this as well and this is twice now
that I'm quoting Edward Snowden today
and I am no a big defender of Snowden
but when he says something that I
believe is accurate I'll tell you
snowden tweeted the ballot stuffing
scene today in Moscow and elsewhere in
the Russian election is an effort to
steal the influence of 140 million plus
people demand justice demand laws and
courts that matter take your future back
want to make one other comment about
this okay and this is a comment about
the toxic left as I'm calling it
Pat's taking feverish notes now there is
this contingent I've mentioned before of
sort of Leninist Hugo Chavez loving
so-called leftists who are saying
there's nothing to see in terms of
Russian influence in the United States
there's nothing to see in
terms of ballot stuffing in Russia
either we have irregularities here in
the United States as well so who are we
to pass judgment on what's going on in
Russia's elections have fun with that
just stay away from me I have no
interest in even engaging with you
discuss this with us on our subreddit
david pakman.com slash our EDD i.t
coming up next I'm ready for this good
old-fashioned exorcism stay with us